salut à vous qui aimez manier votre
cerveau comme personne aujourd'hui on se
fait un bon vieux master class à
l'ancienne un master class des familles
le but de ce master class et de pouvoir
retenir un jeu de cartes en entier
retenir un jeu de cartes en entier ok
c'est un truc qu'on a déjà fait j'ai
tenté une traversée publicitaires on l'a
déjà fait dans la vidéo numéro 79 c'est
à dire la 79e vidéo de l'année mais vous
m'avez beaucoup écrit soit dans les
commentaires soit par message en passant
par mon site internet pour me dire que
c'était compliqué mon premier réflexe a
été de me dire oui mais je n'ai jamais
dit que ce serait facile et mon deuxième
réflexe était de me dire mais j'ai une
méthode plus simple pour ça en même
temps je pourrai leur apprendre alors je
vous explique comment dans ce nouveau
master class génériques
la première chose qu'il faut savoir et
vous vous en doutez sûrement si vous
suivez cette chaîne sait qu'on va passer
par un système d'image dans la vidéo 79
je vous proposais un système de paie aux
personnages action objets reliés à
chaque cas donc ça faisait cinquante
deux fois trois images à retenir plus
les lieux à retenir ça faisait beaucoup
de choses à retenir
j'en ai conscience cent cinquante six
images c'est pas rien retenir en plus
faut d'abord les créé au préalable je
peux comprendre que ça vous rebute
et puis il fallait 18 lieux manteau pour
les déposer est ce que serait pas plus
simple de le faire avec huit images que
vous ne devez pas forcément connaître
par coeur et seulement neuf lieux oui
oui oui
tu m'étonnes quand j'étais un peu plus
jeune j'avais un système pour faire ça
ça permet pas de retenir l'ordre des
cartes en entier je vous dis tout de
suite ça permet de retenir les séquences
rouge et noir et c'est déjà un bon
départ
aussi bien vous pour faire travailler
votre mémoire et commencer à extraire
toutes les possibilités de cette
dernière que pour bluffer les gens en
faisant une petite démonstration en fin
de repas on va transformer les couleurs
de cartes en codes binaires c'est dire
que y'a que des rouges et des noirs dans
un jeu de cartes on va partir que sur
ces deux choses là et bien en quelques
secondes seulement vous êtes capable de
retenir si c'est rouge noir ou en rouge
noir ou noir rouge noir etc
sur les 52 c'est très bluffant je vous
le dis ça paraît rien comme ça mais
c'est très bluffant quand quelqu un
mélange le jeu de cartes
vous le prenez vous le passez en revue
vous refermez vous dit c'est bon je sais
encore plus rigolo si si la personne ne
met de côté durant une heure et au bout
d'une heure vous dis alors tiens je leur
prends et je déteste maintenant que vous
êtes encore capable de le faire c'est
sympathique on va admettre que les
cartons rouges cheval 0 et que les
cartes noir balle un docker et caro 0
pic et réf
et vous n'allez pas retenir 52 cartes
mais seulement 18 séquence puisque vous
allez retenir les séquences par trois
donc à chaque fois qu'il ya trois cartes
qui passe ça donne une séquence ci a
trois rouges puisque le rouge c'est zéro
ça fait 0 0 0
s'il ya rouge noir rouge ça fait 0 1 0
donc déjà on vient de passer de 52
occurrence on va appeler ça des
occurrences 52 occurrence à 18,2 plutôt
cool avant de voir comment les stocker
ces occurrences on va voir comment les
créer il ya seulement huit combinaisons
possibles donc rouge rouge rouge ou
rouge rouge noir ou noir rouge rouge etc
je vais vous les faire en vous
expliquant comment les combinés ensemble
pour créer mes images juillet et me
demandez pas pourquoi j'ai fait ça je me
suis intéressé qu un qui va me permettre
de donner un nom qui va être un petit
code mnémo technique que je vais pouvoir
enfoncer au fond de la tête à l'aide
d'une image si on est sur la première
possibilité à savoir 3
carton rouge ça fait 0 0 0 et pour moi
il ya 0,1 à l'intérieur donc je retiens
que le zéro et avec le z je me fais mon
image quand j'étais plus jeune et que
j'ai utilisé cette possibilité là pour
retenir des suites et de séquences
binaire j'utilisais des personnages que
je connaissais très bien à l'époque donc
je vous donne les miens mais vous en
faites ce que vous voulez 0 ça commence
par z et donc je pense à zorro quand
j'ai trois rouges qui suivent je pense à
zorro ensuite il ya 0 0 1
il ya qu un seul 1 et les complètement à
droite donc je retiens que le dea de
droit tu m'as mnémotechnique ces deux
manières le 1 et à droite droite et avec
le d j'ai choisi donald merveilleux ya
également 0 1 0 et là il ya qu un seul
un oeil au milieu avec le m2 milieu j'ai
choisi milou un mot quand j'étais petit
j'avais des supers héros au top je peux
te le dire et encore vous allez voir
qu'avec le 1 0 0 comme ya qu un seul un
et qu'il est à gauche je pense à gauche
avec le g2 gauche
j'avais choisi gargamel je regrette
maintenant oui oui je regrette oui 5e
possibilité c1 01
moi je pense à encercler parce que le
zéro et tout salir encerclé par les uns
n'oubliez jamais que je suis focus
uniquement sur les 1 et carte noire et
avec le e2 encerclé je pensais à
excalibur ah bon pour la série kaamelott
avec alexandre astier non pour merlin
l'enchanteur de disney quand il ya trois
cartes au noir ça fait 1 1 1 pour moi
c'est la version ultime d1 et avec le
une ultime je pense à hulk oui hulk
juste pour la prononciation pour le son
hulk je vous précise n'oubliez pas de
créer vos propres images ce sera
beaucoup mieux mais vous pouvez garder
ma méthode de droite gauche l'ultime
encerclé ça fonctionne même parce que ça
on le retient quasi instantanée la 7e
possibilité c'est avoir une carte noire
une carte noire une carte rouge soit 1 1
et dans ce cas là vous avez remarqué
qu'il ya 2 1 qui sont à gauche alors moi
j'ai créé un mot avec deux fois le jet
de gauche c'est la gorgone alias méduses
dans la mythologie qui t'a simple regard
pouvez vous transformer en statue de sel
dans ma tête c'est une espèce de bonnes
femmes avec des serpents à la place des
cheveux et le dernier je pense qu'il
vous plaira c'est zéro 1-1 donc une
carte rouge de carte noire etc droite
droite donc c2d et les données pour moi
c'est d'aider des j'espère que vous
souvenez lui c'est d'aider le cochon des
jeux à gratter
non non non c'est pas un placement de
produit vous voyez c'est assez simple de
créer une démo technique pour se
souvenir de l'image que vous avez
construite ou que vous allez construire
vous pouvez très bien le faire
spontanément avec le z 2 0 pourrait
penser à un zèbre par exemple
conseils à chaque fois de garder cette
première lettre de ce procédé
mnémotechnique pour créer votre image
maintenant vous savez les crée quand
vous allez faire défiler le jeu de
cartes dans vos mains vous n'allez pas
pouvoir à chaque fois retenir sans appui
regardez là j'ai déjà passé neuf cartes
y avait déjà trois séquences à retenir à
savoir un gargamel et deux fois hulk se
passe des trucs dans nos têtes
il ya une vie je vous explique comment
vous allez faire vous avez quasiment
créé une nouvelle petite tape de rappel
comme ça très rapide et si vous ne savez
pas ce qu'une table de rappel vous
pouvez quand même regarder la trente
septième vidéo de cette année ainsi que
la 254 in game j'avais fait deux vidéos
qui sont consacrés à ça mais là on va se
servir de la 65e vidéo de cette année à
savoir le palais mentale simplifiée
c'est également appelé la méthode des
lieux cette vidéo là je voulais mais en
fiche ici je voulais mais également dans
la description parce que c'est très
important je vais pas vous refaire toute
l'explication mais c'est ce que vous
allez utiliser assez simplement quand
même vous allez pouvoir imaginer une
pièce que vous connaissez très bien et
dans cette pièce la définir neuf lieux
précis et mentalement vous devez être
absolument capables de vous déplacer
dans cette pièce sur ces neuf lieux dans
le bon sens dans le même sens à chaque
fois c'est un petit truc à choper très
rapide au préalable avant de faire la
démonstration en sait quelque chose que
vous allez décider là maintenant
regardant cette vidéo par exemple moi ça
pourrait très bien être le bureau où je
décide que j'arrive par la porte donc la
porte à mon premier lieu ensuite il ya
ma guitare la guitare c'est le deuxième
lieu et puis je vais tourner comme ça
dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre
pour décider à l'avance de neuf
emplacements une fois que ça c'est fait
vous avez tous les outils c'est bon
c'est terminé quand vous aurez le jeu de
cartes dans les mains vous allez voir
que ça va être très rapide et très
fluide peut-être parler une ou deux
premières fois le temps de de se roder
un peu l'exercice mais vous vous placez
dans votre petit palais mentale juste
celui ci qui sortent quartier pour
l'occasion vous fait passer les trois
premières car là on sait que c'est
gauche puisque c'est un 0 0
donc c'est gargamel ensuite les trois
prochaines ça c'est un hulk puisqu'il
n'ya que des seins c'est le ultime et
moi mon premier spot dans l'exemple que
je ne vous dira dans le bureau c'est
l'apport est bien j'imagine dans ma tête
à la porte du bureau gargamel en premier
c'est important et hulk qui sont en
train de combattre mais vraiment de
combattre c'est à dire que dans ma
représentation comme je lis de gauche à
droite et que je fais le tour dans le
sens des aiguilles d'une montre
j'imagine d'abord gargamel il y à gauche
et c'est hulk qui l'attaquent de l'autre
côté ça prend qu'une seconde à créer
cette image là dans la tête et elle est
marquante
elle va me rester ensuite je vais aller
à mon deuxième spot donc ça je leur
appât pour plus de perturber je sais que
là j'ai encore un hulk et là j'ai encore
un an
j'ai encore de hulk d'affilée donc
j'avais dit que c'était à la guitare et
bien je veux imaginer de hulk en train
de jouer avec ma guitare un qui la
gratte et l'autre qui fait les notes
là ça me fait la gorgone c'est-à-dire
gauche gauche vous savez j'ai à 1 0 est
juste à côté j'ai zorro donc à mon
troisième emplacement mental je l'aï
imaginé d'abord la gorgone qui est donc
sur la gauche en train de pétrifier
euros comme une statue de sel
vous avez donc compris qu'en doublant
les images par spot vous avez que neuf
emplacements à retenir alors on pourrait
aller un petit peu plus loin et on peut
aller plus loin parce que c'est quand
même un master class en se disant que si
vous voulez vous pouvez même mentalement
avec un petit effort supplémentaire
savoir précisément quelles cartes du jeu
et rouge ou noir si on vous dit la 40e
cartes du jeu par exemple vous savez que
vous avez 6 images par spot donc 6 x 6
36 c'est ce qui se rapproche le plus de
40 donc ça va être votre 7ème spot que
va être l'image est 40 moins 36 il m'en
reste 4 donc c'est pas ma première image
mais c'est la deuxième image de ce spot
et plus précisément le premier code
binaire de la séquence de trois qui
représente cette image ça paraît
peut-être pas simple dit comme ça mais
si ça vous intéresse repasser lentement
la séquence avec un papier un crayon et
ce sera beaucoup plus clair si vous avez
l'esprit un petit peu comme ça merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère que
ça vous aura plu n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs à laisser un bon et gros et
dont pouce en l'air comme ça parce que
c'est important mais que si ça vous a
plu
n'hésitez pas également à m'en parler
dans les commentaires d'une parce que je
les lis déjà ça c'est quand même
important de le préciser et de deux
parce que parfois j'y réponds quand je
peux et quand c'est des choses assez
essentiel mais j'ai vu que vous
répondiez souvent entre vous et ça c'est
vraiment cool c'est un peu l'esprit du
truc menthe à l'eau tu vois passer un
excellent dimanche n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner avant de partir vous pouvez
cliquer ici au bas de la vidéo mais ici
aussi également non je me trompe c'est
juste là c'est ici que vous pouvez
cliquer et ça marche également sur les
téléphones c'est la petite nouveauté you
tube du moment qu'ils avaient commencé à
mettre en place et à y est c'est bon et
puis sinon comme tous les jours avec le
mandat le blog rendez vous demain à 17h
bon dimanche chose